but point out that um last fall
um aaron was a finalist in the student
paper competition
at the american medical informatics
association meeting
and um he also continues to work with
colleagues
in ophthalmology studying retinopathy or
prematurity
including dr chang so for those of
you who don't know or don't remember
the process will be that
um aaron will um give his talk
um we'll then open it up to questions
from
whoever is here when those questions are
done
the public will leave and we'll leave
behind his
committee to ask him any further
questions and then the committee will
ask him
to leave and make a decision whether or
not he has successfully defended his
peace his dissertation so i'm going to
turn it over to
aaron all right
thank you bill for the introduction um
and thank you everyone for taking the
time out of your day to come attend my
dissertation defense
which as the name implies here is going
to be around machine learning and how we
can use that to solve
problems in this disease called
retinopathy of prematurity
and before i get started i would just
like to make some quick acknowledgements
if i didn't do any of this on my own
first to my dissertation advisory
committee for
all the research health and planning and
execution that they provided
um the irop consortium for collecting
all the data that i'm using
in this study um especially susan osmo
for
helping to organize that data and then
you know distribute it to me
to the d mice faculty staff and students
for all the training and support they
provided
and then of course the national library
of medicine for the funding that they
provided to me over these past
four and a half years
so retinopathy of prematurity or rop
is a disease of the retinal vasculature
that affects premature infants who are
born prior to 31 weeks of gestation
and who weigh less than fifteen hundred
one grams at birth
and it's one of the leading causes of
childhood blindness in both
developing countries and developed
countries
so the retina is that light-sensitive
tissue that's on the back of the eye
that allows you to
actually see and there's three major
features here
so the first is the macula which is this
densely populated
populated area of cone photoreceptors
and your cones are responsible for
allowing you to see in color vision but
also because they're so
densely packed in this one area they
also provide humans with high visual
acuity
we also have the optic disc which
collects light information
from all the various cone photoreceptors
or all of the various
photoreceptors in the eye and then
transmits them to the brain for visual
processing
and then we have the retinal blood
vessels which are here to provide oxygen
and nutrients
to those photoreceptor cells and other
supporting cells of the eye
um so you can imagine that if you had
any sort of disruption to any three of
these major features
that could disrupt your visual acuity
and
potentially cause blindness
now normally about 16 weeks after a baby
is conceived the retinal blood vessels
begin to form
and then between 26 and 30 weeks the eye
really begins to develop at an
increased pace and then finally the baby
is born sometime between
38 and 42 weeks but if a baby is born
extremely prematurely
the eye never has a chance to develop at
that increased
pace so a lot of it is left
underdeveloped
but there are many other organs in the
body that are also underdeveloped
and one of the most critical ones is the
lungs
so to make sure that we can keep a baby
alive we supply them with supplemental
oxygen
but this has the negative effect of
inhibiting the growth of the retinal
vasculature
and that's because normally the maternal
womb is actually
hypoxic and this drives the retina the
retinal vascular
to start growing towards the peripheral
retina so that more photoreceptor cells
can form there
but when we you know put them in this
extra oxygen they no longer feel the
need to start growing like that anymore
but once the babies return back to room
air those undeveloped areas of the
retina become hypoxic once again
and the retinal vasculature starts to
grow in an uncontrolled manner
towards those areas to provide those
oxygen nutrients
but those retinal blood vessels that
form are extremely weak and fragile
so eventually what happens is they end
up rupturing they bleed into the eye and
then they scar
over but the scar itself
anchors the retina to that particular
portion in the back of the eye
and as the eye continues to grow the
scar pulls on the retina and can
cause it to detach from the back of the
eye and can cause either
a partial retinal detachment or a
complete retinal detachment
and this can cause complete blindness
now to start looking for the presence of
this uncontrolled
retinal vasculature physicians are
really looking for the presence of plus
disease
which is described as venous dilation
and arterial tortuosity
and you can see that what plus disease
what the retinal blood vessels look like
compared to an eye with normal vascular
over here
and then we also have this kind of
in-between condition known as pre-plus
disease
which just describes vascular cure
that's not that's
you know not normal it's abnormal
looking but it's not yet severe enough
to be considered plus disease
and what's critical about this is that
all of these
these pre this normal pre-plus plus
disease kind of spectrum here
is tightly correlated to the need for
treatment for rop
so babies who have plus disease almost
always get treated for rop
some babies who develop pre-plus disease
will eventually develop
plus disease and need treatment or have
self-regressing
you know rop and then the normal
vascular babies
never really need to be treated
so to make sure that we're catching all
cases of plus disease
we have highly sensitive screening
guidelines and these
um screenings begin as early as 31 weeks
of post menstrual age
and the follow-up is based on the
severity of that retrovascular truth
so we can have a follow-up that occurs
you know less than one week up to
three weeks and then a baby is
discharged when there's
um only when there's unequivocally
regressing rop
but the downside to these highly
sensitive screening guidelines where
we're
just screening all babies who weigh you
know less than 1501 grams and who are
born prior to 31 weeks of gestation
is that they have very poor specificity
so
roughly 85 to 90 percent of the babies
that we do screen
for rop never develop treatment
requiring rop
and this is not great because these
exams are
physiologically stressful and we're
adding
we're increasing the screening burden
that's placed on an already limited
number of rop specialists
and then finally many of these exams
like have to be performed
in person so getting care into
rural areas and developing countries is
very difficult
so to kind of start to get care into
those areas
physicians and researchers have tried to
implement methods such as telemedicine
where we can increase the geographic
area in which experts can provide care
and thus increase the total number of
infants who are screened for rlp
but there are again some negative
consequences
associated with that so the first is
that the required exam frequency
for telemedicine is about once a week um
we can't
be stretching out we're not allowed to
stretch out these exams to three weeks
um so that increases the physiological
stress for all of these babies you know
who
are screened via telemedicine because of
this required exam frequency
um it also increases that physician
screening burden
because now we're you know uh we're
examining more babies
and there has to be someone else on the
other end of this pipeline to read these
images and provide a diagnosis
and then finally there's an issue of
having reduced accuracy and reliability
when low quality retinal images are
provided
so if a low quality image comes through
it's possible that
a physician could misdiagnose a
treatment requiring baby as
non-treatment requiring
or um the physician might not feel
comfortable
making a diagnosis so they say hey you
need to bring that baby back in for
another
um screening examination which again is
physiologically stressful
now we have seen some automated methods
for the diagnosis of rop
coming in and these do help to reduce
that physician screening burden
but they still have some of those same
negative consequences associated with
them
namely you know there's still that
required exam frequency
and the reduced accuracy and reliability
with low quality images
so if we try to kind of sum this up what
we can see is that there are three major
needs here
the first is that we need have a need
for automated image quality assessment
for retinal fungus images we need to
find a way to reduce the physiological
stress that's placed on these babies
and we also need to find a way to reduce
that rop specialist screening burden
and to solve these we're going to use
three specific aims
so in the first specific aim we're going
to build a convolutional neural network
that can discriminate between
acceptable and non-acceptable quality
images
in the second aim we're going to build a
risk model for treatment requiring rlp
patients that can perform better than
the current
birth weight and gestational age model
so that way we can at least
increase our specificity and not have to
screen some
so much of the population so often
and then finally we want to try to
reduce that rlp specialist screening
burden
by developing personalized reference
standard images
of quest disease so that somewhat so
that our
non-rlp specialists can um can screen
the uh less less
the lower risk to the lower risk rop
babies
and this could be someone who's you know
maybe not an rlp specialist but still
qualified to perform exams someone like
an ophthalmic or a pediatric
ophthalmologist
and to do all of this we're going to use
a data set that's been collected by the
imaging and informatics and retinopathy
of prematurity
consortium kind of mouthful kind of a
mouthful so i'm just going to say the
irop data set here
and this is a data set that has over 950
subjects that have been collected from
nine north american study centers
and there are over 32 000 retinal fungus
images in here
of different views of the eye and there
are clinical factors for every baby in
here
and importantly every exam for every
baby
has an expert consensus diagnosis of
plus disease and various other
aspects of the disease that's been
formed by six or more
expert rope graders
so aim one is the quality control for
retinal fundus images
and up here i just have some images that
have been determined to be acceptable
possibly acceptable or not of not
acceptable quality
for the diagnosis of rop as determined
by
um a consensus of rop experts and you
can see
it seems like you might be able to use
some pretty basic image quality metrics
to uh to figure out the difference
between acceptable possibly acceptable
not acceptable images
you could use it looks like you could
use like a brightness contrast metric
here
to see the difference but the problem
here is that these are some really nice
carry picked examples that i've pulled
out for you
and when you look at some real world
examples
the difference between these categories
is far less stark
so in an acceptable quality image what i
see is that
you know you can see even though all of
these images are hazy
you can still see the retinal
vasculature extending into the
peripheral retina
whereas you start to lose that on these
lower quality images
so we need a model that isn't looking at
necessarily the global information of
this
um of these images but rather these uh
you know these
these uh these these finer details of
the images
so that's why we're going to use um a
model called the convolutional neural
network
which is really great for being able to
classify images
and the one we're going to use is called
inception b3
which was developed by google and it's
been trained on the
imagenet database and that's important
because the imagenet database
contains about 14 million images from
thousands of different categories so it
has
images of cats and airplanes and
dishwashers and all sorts of different
things
and importantly what that means is that
in the first layers here or these
you know these first layers it's learned
this model has learned what basic
shapes look like so it's learned you
know how to identify what a circle looks
like what a
triangle square all those things look
like and then into these later layers
it learns specific combinations of those
features
um and how they correlate to each of
these different image classifications
so it might you know here in these
layers we might learn what an
almond shape looks like in a triangle
and then these later layers it learns
well
if you have two almond shapes together
and then an upside down triangle below
it it might be a cat
right so we can use this model and
harness it and leverage it for
our specific use case and what we can do
is freeze these early layers that have
learned these basic shapes
and then fine-tune these later layers
for our specific use case
which is going to be to classify images
that as
either acceptable quality or as possibly
acceptable or not acceptable quality
so we're going to make this into a
binary classification task
and we're going to do this we're going
to just split our data into the
canonical you know
80 20 training test data sets there and
we're going to perform five-fold
cross-validation
and importantly there is an overlap in
subjects
subject size between our training and
test data sets
and what we found through fivefold cross
validation
is that the aucs range from about 0.953
up to 0.965 so this suggests the model
is performing pretty well
or each of these individual models are
performing pretty well and they don't
seem to be over fitting to the data and
that they should
generalize well so
to further test that generalizability um
we took the best performing model which
was model 1 with the auc of 0.965
and evaluated it on our held out test
data set
and again it performed with an auc of
0.965
so this suggests that this model does
generalize very well it should work
pretty well on
similar samples from the same population
that it's been trained on
now importantly this model has also been
trained
we should keep in mind that this model
has been trained on
labels that were determined by a
physician's ability to diagnose images
for telemedicine purposes um but it
might be that we want to use this model
you know for uh other methods such as
you know like the automated methods that
i was kind of previously talking about
and those methods might require images
to be more
um maybe of higher quality or it might
be able to get away with lesser quality
images
so to see if this model if we could
confidently
adjust that threshold at which we're
binning images as
acceptable or or not acceptable we
had physicians first um
take a subset of 30 images from the test
data set
uh and we had them perform pairwise
comparisons on these images
as basically asking them which of these
images of these two images
which is of better quality and after
performing so many comparisons we were
able to develop
a ranking of the images for each
individual expert
and then from that we're able to create
an expert consensus rating
and then we also took those same 30
images and fed them through the model
and then rather than having the model
provide us with a classification of the
image of being you know either
acceptable quality or not acceptable
quality
we had to provide us with the
probability of an image belonging to the
acceptable quality class
and then with those probabilities we
just ordered the images
or formed a rank for them um based off
of that probability ranging from zero to
one
and what we found was that first experts
were
highly correlated with one another in
terms of their ranking of image quality
so their spearman's rank correlation
range from 0.89
up to 0.97 but if we look at how
the model compared with individual
experts we see that its rank correlation
range from 0.86
up to 0.93 and then just to further
confirm this
the cnn still uh correlated very highly
with the
with a consensus ranking here so this
suggests that this model
can not only you know uh classify images
acceptable or not acceptable
but that we should be able to um you
know tune that decision threshold
for whatever specific use case we want
to use this in
now one major limitation of the study
is kind of centered around the
population that we used for this
and that is the fact that this is a
north american data set
and that retinal pigmentation is highly
correlated with
race so this model contains basically a
bunch of
white babies in it and there are some
severely underrepresented groups in this
data set
so if we were going to be using this
model for
some of those under represented groups
we it either needs to be
you know kind of taken with a grain of
salt or ideally if you could retrain a
model
um you know on a data set that was made
up of mostly those underrepresented
groups
that would be great
so key takeaways here are that we can
detect acceptable quality images from
those which are not
and we can adjust that threshold fairly
confidently
for whatever potential application we
want to use this for whether that be
for you know quality assurance for
imaging technicians basically
if we could implement this right at the
bedside right at the point of care so
that
the second image was taken someone could
be alerted as to whether or not that
image was
of acceptable quality but it could also
be used in telemedicine or
automated disease diagnosis pipelines
and in fact we're
currently kind of working out some kinks
and trying to get this into our irop dl
system
which is an automated method for uh plus
disease detection
but this also has bigger implications
too
um this can be used for other ophthalmic
eye diseases
um it can be used for authentic eye
diseases that use different
imaging modalities or could just be used
for entirely different
diseases in imaging modalities
now in aim 2 our goal is going to be to
predict which children will develop
treatment requiring rop
better than the current birth weight and
gestational age model that we use
and before we start doing that we really
need to think about what factors are
going to contribute to physician
acceptance
and the clinical implementation of this
model
and the three that we've kind of
identified here are performance
transparency
and ease of use so
this model needs to be needs to have
high performance
and by that we need a model that's going
to have extremely high sensitivity
because remember the cost of an
incorrect prediction here is going to be
lifelong visual impairment but for this
model to also be practical
it also has to have high specificity
so remember we have a model right now
that has very low set specificity
so even having something above 50 would
be ideal
this model also needs to be transparent
meaning it needs to be highly
interpretable
by physicians so what comes to mind
instantly is just something like a
simple linear model and since this is a
classification task
we'll do logistic regression um but we
can use some tools to kind of boost the
performance of this
you know namely using elastic net
regularization
class weighting and then we can tune
that decision threshold to be a little
bit more sensitive for our cases here
and then finally this model also needs
to be easy to use
um it needs to have a limited number of
predictors we can't have something with
you know 50 or 60 predictors because
we want this model to be able to be used
right at the bedside
and these predictors need to be common
among all babies and easy to acquire it
can't be something where you have to
send something out to a lab and wait
uh we want it to be able to you know be
pretty instantaneous
so if we look at a whole list of
potential predictors there are
many in here but if we start looking
through which ones are common among all
babies
we can start to narrow it down and then
if we look at which ones are easy to
measure
we really get um we really find that
like birth weight
gestational age and as of late vascular
severity
are easier to measure
and vascular severity hasn't been
included in any risk models
to date and that's for a particular
reason so
here i have an image or figure from a
paper by dr campbell
and what you see here is we have each of
these rectangles representing an image
here along the x-axis
and the color of these rectangles
represents the diagnosis that this image
was given
and then on the y-axis we have a
reference standard diagnosis
and then eight individual rop experts
so if you look at expert eight for
instance they say well all of these
images here
are images of plus disease but the
reference standard says well actually
these images that youtuber plus disease
are only pre-plus disease
and then you contrast that with expert
one who says only these images are plus
disease
and the rest are pre-plus even though
the rsd says well these images are
also plus disease so you have this issue
of
inter-expert disagreement you have some
people who are overcallers of disease
and some people are who are under
callers of disease and you can't really
use that in a model because
their diagnosis is so squishy here
and a huge reason why it's so squishy is
because
we try to bin this vascular severity
essentially
into three different categories of
normal pre-plus and plus disease
but ideally this whole vascular severity
is actually a continuous spectrum
um you know it's not that there are
three different categories it should be
of this continuous
uh line here and so we can form
a a um a vascular severity score
and uh some people in our lab have
actually done that so
uh postdoc in our lab james brown uh not
the
singer artist but a great guy still uh
he um built a model where you can take a
red little thundus image and you can
convert that into
a retinal vessel map by segmenting it
with a unit
that if that vessel map is then sent
into the irop dl system which is here to
classify plus disease
the irop dl system eventually spits out
what's called a soft max layer so this
will give a probability of that image
being normal
p plus and plus and importantly all of
these
probabilities must sum to one and then
whichever of these has the maximum
probability
receives the diagnosis so if there's a
probability of 90 percent here and
normal
then the image is called normal but dr
campbell came up with an idea where
you can make a continuous spectrum here
if you take the probability of that
image being normal
add that to five times the probability
of that image being pre-plus
and nine times that um probability of
that image being plus
so if you have an image that is you know
100
a plus disease image it's gonna have a
vascular severity score of nine
if it's 100 normal it's going to have a
vascular severity score of one
and everything in between will fall
somewhere in between one and nine
and so he further followed up on this
and just examined a set of images
um you know a larger set of images and
what you find is that
the vascular severity score does seem
um the i guess the the uh the vascular
severity score that we've seen
does seem to correlate very highly with
actual vascular severity
and then another physician dr taylor
did an interesting study where he looked
at the vascular severity score
between children who developed treatment
requiring rop
and those who did not and looked at
their vascular severity scores over time
and what you find is that the babies who
have
who eventually develop treatment
requiring rop start to have this
diverging vascular severity score
starting as early as 32 weeks of
post-menstrual age
but what's important to note here is
that this vascular severity score the
median score here
is about 1.5 which is not
cause for alarm for any physician there
they're going to say this baby looks
normal
to me but but it's actually starting to
diverge here
and importantly this diverging vascular
severity score
begins about a month before the actual
treatment requiring rlp diagnosis comes
through
so that means that this might be a
really great predictor
of the need for treatment in the future
so to do this we again split our data
set into those you know
the training test data sets with the 80
20 split here
and we still perform five-fold
cross-validation
we are going to say that all images that
are used here have to be of acceptable
quality because those are the
because they're going to go through this
iropdl system here
and then we're going to look at that
first exam at least for our training set
we're going to look at that first exam
to occur between the 32 and 34 weeks
post-medical age
but then for our test data set we're
going to open it up a bit and say well
any baby that comes in after 32 weeks
will use this model so
if you're coming in at 35 weeks we're
not going to turn you away
and then to make this model more
predictive in nature
rather than diagnostic we're going to
say that
for babies in the training data set that
treatment requiring rlp diagnosis
has to occur at least seven or more days
from that initial exam to occur
between 32 and 34 weeks and that's
because we want this model to be very
sensitive
to those slight changes in vascular
severity
um rather than just picking up on a baby
who has treatment requiring rop
when they come in but of course in the
real world we're not going to know
when a baby is going to develop
treatment requiring rop or even if they
will
um so we're going to say you can come in
and you can have
treatment requiring rop i mean let's
hope that our model will actually catch
that disease
so when we just evaluate the univariate
predictors here
and see how well they performed on these
on our in our training set with 5-fold
cross validation
we see that the area under the precision
recall curve is about 0.29
and the area under the precision recall
curve is going to be our main metric of
model performance here
and that's because this is such an
imbalanced data set
so a null model would actually have an
area under the precision recall of about
0.1 so when we see something 0.29 that's
actually
fairly predictive and then when we look
at all possible combinations of just
these three
basic predictors here we find that a
combination of
gestational age and vascular severity
has the highest area under the precision
recall curve
of 0.35
now we wanted to make sure that this
model was again highly sensitive
so during the training phase uh we made
the class weights
inversely proportional to the class
frequencies and that's so basically
um you know so if i if the model
incorrectly
predicted that a treatment requiring
baby would not develop
treat requiring disease then it was
penalized more heavily than
if the in the reverse happened there but
we can also
tune the decision threshold here and to
do that we're going to use the f
beta score and we can set beta we can
increase beta to
increase um our weighting
of of of or sorry we can so we can
prioritize our minimization
of false negatives over five positives
and we want to do that because our
potential cost of a
wrong prediction again is a lifelong
visual
impairment here so to strongly
prioritize that
minimization we set beta equal to four
um
and we're hoping that this will you know
catch all babies who have treated
requiring disease
and still have a relatively high uh
specificity here
and when we did that we found that that
threshold uh occurred
the maximum threshold or sorry the
maximum f score
f4 score occurred at a threshold of 0.33
so when we evaluate this model on our
held out test data set again of subjects
this model's never seen before
it identified 100 percent or 132 of the
eyes
that developed treatment requiring our
rop and didn't miss a single one
and importantly it had a specificity of
51 percent
now we also wanted to evaluate how this
model would perform
on an independent desktop test data set
um
so we collected we kind of have one that
was then collected from a hospital in
salem oregon
and it's much smaller but again it was
able to identify
all eyes that developed treat requiring
rop
and still was able to rule out this time
you know over 50 percent and near 60
percent of the eyes
that would never develop requiring rop
and what's really cool about this is
that we're identifying these babies
um you know somewhere between 3.4 and
3.7 weeks
before this diagnosis actually occurs so
that means that we can really start to
tell our
rlp specialist page these are the babies
you need to focus on and these other
ones are
going to be less worrisome
so again uh just kind of key takeaways
here
for rop we built a model that we can
identify you know all babies that will
develop treatment requiring rop
just as the current birth weight
gestational age model but importantly
we can reduce that rop screening burden
in the associated physiological stress
by more than 50
and this is huge because this currently
outperforms other rop risk models
um and we've shown that this is working
on a pretty diverse you know
large data set here collected from all
over north america
um now our future work is going to kind
of aim at
these validation studies we're still
going to start to collect data from
those
salem oregon salem oregon hospital
and we'd like to try to get our hands on
a larger another large
north american cohort study here it is
proving a little bit difficult because
many of those larger rlp data sets don't
also include
associated imaging data so that's just
one challenge
but we are looking at other methods if
we can further improve specificity
especially of those who've been you know
you know uh so if we die or if we
predict a baby's gonna develop treatment
requiring rlp
can we further you know improve
specificity and we're looking at methods
like
um you know maybe looking at the oxygen
exposure that they've had since birth
because that can play a role here
um and then finally another limitation
here is just regarding the population
that this model has been trained on
we actually have data to suggest that
the vascular severity score isn't
affected by the popular or by which
population and that's because those
retinal fundus images are first
converted into retinal vessel maps
so that kind of removes that that
pigmentation and
the associated race data there but there
are difference in differences in
gestational age and differences between
which babies develop
treatment requiring rlp and their
gestational age so we find that in
developing countries often the babies
who develop that disease
can be older and larger than what we see
in developed countries
now in the final aim our goal here is
going to be
going to be to develop personalized
reference standard images
um again so that we
i guess here i'll explain uh so the
reason that we want to do this
is that we have a model now that can
predict which babies will
are likely to develop treatment
requiring rop and then also filter out a
bunch of babies who we don't think will
develop treatment requiring rop
but we can't just say well we're never
going to examine these babies again
i think the better thing to think here
is that there aren't no risk of
treatment requiring rp they're just
low risk so those low-risk babies
could instead be examined again by like
someone like a pediatric ophthalmologist
while we have our rop specialists focus
on these children who
are predicted to develop treatment
requiring rop
and to do this we're going to you know
help them diagnose using these
these personalized reference standard
images and there is
a current reference standard image for
plus disease
but it has some associated problems and
the first thing is it's about 40 years
old so that
the camera technology at the time is
really the main problem here
and when you look at these images uh
you can it looks like the amount of
dilation and tortuosity that's required
for a plus disease image
is much higher than what we see on
this image here so this image on the
right is an image that has an expert
consensus diagnosis of plus disease
and this image looks far less severe
than this image but
really it's still plus disease
so to do this we're going to have a
model we're going to take a patient's
image and we're going to use that
that previously trained unit model to
develop a retinal vessel map
but then we're going to use a generative
adversarial network to modify that
retinal vessel map
to look like to instead of looking like
normal to look like it has plus disease
while still keeping the stain the same
backbone and structure here
and then we're going to use another
generative adversarial network or again
to convert that vessel map into a
realistic looking
retinal fundus image here
so just for a little bit of background
again is basically two convolutional
neural networks that are pitted against
one another
and one is a discriminator the
discriminator is kind of like the
the image quality one that i built
earlier where it's just you know trying
to
tell the difference between data that's
real and data that's fake
and then we have the generator which its
job is to generate data
so it's going to make fake data and the
discriminator is fed
real and fake data after the generator
creates its faith data
and then it makes its you know guesses
on what the images are
and then it the lost statistics from
that model are
output back to the generator and the
generator updates
um its weight so it's starting to learn
what it's doing right and what it's
doing wrong
and what we hope is that we get to a
point where
the generator can create data that's so
realistic looking
that the discriminator calls it real
so in the first half of this aim our
goal is going going to be to convert
retinal vessel maps into those retinal
fundus images
and we're going to try to tackle this
first because there's really no point in
us being able to convert between
a normal and plus disease vessel map if
we can't even get that vessel map
back into a usable image for a position
so what we're going to use here is
called a paired image
dam and basically the paired image gain
requires that you have a label and an
associated output
like this and you can see why our this
is a great use case for us because we
have this label of this vessel map
in the associated output
so when we pull kind of an off-the-shelf
model and feed
our retinal images or our vessel maps
through there we find that we can
actually
generate some fairly realistic looking
retinal fungus images here if we look
closely you can see the presence of
these
smaller blood vessels and these are
called coronal blood vessels
and these patterns shouldn't be
shouldn't exist in here because
the idea of our of these vessel maps is
that they contain only the main arteries
and veins
but after some investigation i found
that some very low level pixel
information that you can't see with the
naked
eye actually contains information about
these colloidal blood vessel patterns
so i filtered those out and then
retrained the scan
and what we find is that we can still
recreate these images
and without those choroidal blood vessel
patterns but the image quality seems to
suffer a little bit
and if we measure that using the
structural similarity index measure or
the ssim
we see that it does that does seem to be
the case here
and the ssim is ideal because it's not
only looking
you know between it's not it it
basically uses
whatever image you have this generated
image and it's comparing it to this
reference image
and it's not looking only at just the
you know the color
and brightness contrast and similarities
but it's also looking at the local
structure
of these images which was really helpful
for identifying you know making sure
that
the actual retinal blood vessels are
have the same pattern
and when we ask our experts can they
detect the difference between real
and generated images uh they were able
to do so pretty easily
but what we really care about is can you
diagnose these images
and when we send had them evaluate just
a subset of our test data set here
we can see that their diagnosis between
real images
and um and generated images whether or
not they had choroidal blood vessel
patterns
present seem to be pretty similar and we
can
evaluate this using the cochrane mantle
hansel test which suggests that these
contingency tables are not statistically
different from one another
and if we also compare the expert's
diagnosis
together the weighted cohen's catheter
metric also says that there's near
perfect agreement between
experts um diagnosis of real images
compared to generated images um again
whether or not they had cradle blood
vessel patterns present
but we wanted to see now so now that we
know that experts can
you know reliably diagnose these images
and they see you know
they have a fairly high uh structural
similarity index measure and they're
still receiving the same diagnoses
we wanted to see if we could you know
trick the experts into this
at this point into believing these
images were real
um so i used a much higher capacity gan
this time and it took
quite a few days to train here but
eventually i was able to
create retinal fungus images or generate
retinal fungus images from retinal
vessel maps
that look very realistic and they're
they rather than being a size of 256 by
256
they're now the actual size of a real
retinal fungus image
so they look like they're very high
quality and what's kind of cool is that
this model
even though it doesn't this model was
trained on those
vessel maps that don't have the corrodor
blood vessel patterns
but it still attempts to input some of
them to make them look more realistic
and when we look at the structural
similarity index measure here
we see that it's nearly double that of
these images
that um that that what am i trying to
say
due to double that of these images that
didn't have the coronal blood vessel
patterns
so it suggests that these images should
be just as diagnosable
as these as these uh lesser quality
images
and these images were not statistically
you know
different in their diagnosis from real
images
but what we did want to know was could
experts identify images that were
generated here
by the sewer model so we had a set of
four
new experts who weren't at all had no
idea what the study was about
um and just asked them to look at 50
real images and 50 generated images
and tried to pick out which ones were
real and which ones were fake
and what we found is that they pretty
much were not able to do so
um there was one protector for
the difference between between real and
fake images
but most of them were not and the expert
majority
classification here was again not
statistically significant
so key takeaways here that we can
develop or
generate these synthetic retinal images
that are highly realistic and hard for
even experts to identify and what's most
important is that they are structurally
similar
to their real image counterparts and
that was evidenced both by the
structural similarity index measure
and the fact that they received the same
diagnoses as their real image
counterparts
now the second half of this aim was just
to augment the vascular severity of
those retinal vessel maps
so that we can make them look more like
plus disease and for that we're going to
use what's called an
unpaired image gan so in the previous
dam we had you know a label an
associated output
here we just know that we have you know
an image that
looks like something and we want it to
go to like another modality essentially
so we have an image that goes from you
know either a painting by monet to a
real image or a picture of a zebra that
we want to convert to a horse
so for us we're going to try to take
this image that looks normal and convert
it to something that looks like it's
plus disease
while still keeping most of the image
the same
and these models are far harder to train
here
this took a lot of time but i had to
kind of fiddle around
with uh getting the discriminator and
generator to learn at the same
rate so at first i had a problem with
the discriminator
learning what a plus disease image
looked like faster than the generator
which basically caused the generator to
just give up on trying to produce real
images
and it just passed through the same
image that it got
and then i had an issue where i finally
got to a point where i could get the
generator learning a little bit faster
but then it was going too fast
and it was learning faster than the
discriminator
which meant that it would basically
create these kind of garbage patterns in
here
that fooled the discriminator into
thinking this image was plus disease
even though this retinal vasculature
here
isn't medically plausible
and then finally i got to a point where
i could develop these retinal
these uh or i could generate these
retinal vessel maps that look like they
had
increased dilation and tortuosity here
but i needed to evaluate that
on its models or on a on a validation
data set
and figure out like is this actually
plus disease or is it only pre-plus
disease
so after kind of generating images on
our validation data set
i sent those images through the iropdl
system that we have
and had it evaluate a set of images
and 100 of the images that were
that were supposed to be converted from
normal to plus were diagnosis plus
and again 100 of the images that were
supposed to be converted from pre-plus
to plus disease
were also done so
so once i got to this point where i
could get 100 of the images
uh in the validation data set being
successfully converted
i then evaluated on the test data set
and there's where um again we was able
to get 100 of the images can
successfully converted from normal to
plus disease
and then most of the images almost 100
percent of the images
converted from pre-plus to plus disease
now if we take this whole gamm uh
pipeline and put it together we get some
pretty interesting results here so on
the top row
i have uh two images two retinal fungus
images from two different babies
and then i have and these babies came in
with normal looking vasculature and
eventually each of these eyes here
developed
plus disease and then on the bottom row
i have the predictions
of what these eyes would look like with
plus disease based on these
initial images that came through
and what you can see is that there are a
lot of similarities here so you can see
that also this vessel here
that's also up here this smaller one has
been predicted to be
more dilated and tortuous and you see
that over here
on this image on the right you still see
a lot of the same similarities here
where you're getting these dilated and
tortuous
vessels that are being predicted but of
note there are
some vessels that are being predicted
that aren't
actually present so this model is not
actually predicting the exact disease
appearance but it is predicting the
relative
disease appearance
so key takeaway here is that we can
generate these personalized
reference standard images that are you
know highly realistic because they are
so medically plausible
and that experts can't tell the
difference between which images are real
and which are fake
and we can predict that relative disease
severity
which means that we can facilitate the
rop screening exams
by those non-experts you know that are
performed on these lower risk
children now some major limitations here
is that this is not going to predict
exactly how the disease will present um
so that's something that definitely
needs to be kept in mind here
and there's obviously a lot more i think
some more validation
should probably go into this and um
it's also not going to predict the exact
disease severity
so if you think back to the one to nine
scale that we've talked about
um i'm just taking an image and making
it go from normal to plus but again
that's there's that spectrum of disease
severity there so
it could be that i'm producing images
that look like a nine but plus disease
in a baby might only
look like a seven and it could cause a
physician not to want to treat so
we're also going to look into predicting
along that one to nine vascular severity
scale there and then i think another
future
direction here that could be really fun
and interesting is synthesizing data
sets
um and i think this is really important
for diseases that are
rare or difficult to collect for one
reason or another
so we're going to kind of toy around
with that idea moving forward
so ultimately what we've done is we have
trained a convolutional neural network
to
discern between acceptable quality
non-acceptable quality images
and this model can be used for a variety
of potential applications again
it would be ideal if it could be used
right at the bedside but it can also be
used for telemedicine or automated
disease diagnosis systems
we've also built a treatment requiring
risk model
that can predict all infants who will
develop the disease
but also reduce that screening burden by
50
or more and another key factor here is
that this model is highly parsimonious
so
you know it just uses gestational age
which is one of the predictors that we
currently use
and then it uses this novel deep
learning derived vascular severity score
which again you can just upload a
retinal fundus image
to a web server and it spits that image
out or it spits that uh
number out for you and we're even seeing
the advent of you know uh
retinal fundus camera attachments that
can be put on mobile phones
so this is a becoming like a very viable
option
uh for even places that are you know
like developing countries and rural
areas
and then finally we've in aim 3 we've
trained again pipeline to produce these
personalized reference standard images
of plus disease
so that we can allow expert or
non-experts to examine
our lower risk infants and thus reduce
that expert
the rop expert screening burden and
reduce the physiological stress
um on these babies because they don't
necessarily need to be screened you know
once
um once a week if they're going by
telemedicine they could be screened you
know up to two or three weeks instead
um so with that i will happily conclude
and open it up to questions um i am
interested
in any other ideas that you guys might
have for
um this game pipeline that i've
developed too
so yeah thank you
thanks thanks aaron that that's a
excellent
talk um any
questions from the audience
either unmute yourself or
type them in the chat probably simpler
um
to unmute
another question it's probably very
simple one so hi aaron and um
very nice research and presentation
thank you
um so you use the word instantaneous
and i was wondering if that's because of
you modulating the ml pipeline
or using a strong framework or
kind of both of them uh can you sorry
clarify instantaneous where did i
say that so the output of your machine
learning you know you said it's
instantaneous
the physicians need to um
come up with a decision right there and
then um
given the trainings that you're doing on
these images um
how fast are we talking about and how
how is it possible for it to be that
fast um
you know is it your ml pipeline uh
that's making it that fast or
a strong framework or other things yeah
i think it's just the pipeline i mean so
are you just to clarify even further are
you talking about specific aim
like one of the specific games or um
or just all of them in general
um based on your experience probably all
of them i'm
assuming that all of them are packed
yeah
um so like a big thing is like you know
training these pipelines is
very like gpu intensive and takes a lot
um you know of computational power as
i'm sure
you know but um for doing inference it's
pretty
simple now um you know it can be on a
cpu and it goes
fairly quickly um the quality control
model
is is very fast um
it's like on the order like if you were
to you know ask a
logistic regression model to perform
some get you some sort of output
um so this sounds like a framework and
not like something that
um comes down to breaking down your ml
pipeline
and stuff yeah correct
got it awesome thank you so much thank
you
any other any other questions i i i
actually did i don't
have a question either because i think
you covered it so well but i
i i actually do want to say that
um i i'm very um um
i i think it's really great that you've
taken a very clinical perspective here
on you know you know you're applying the
machine learning
in a very specific uh clinical context
in you know particular for example when
we do screening
you know high sensitivity is is really
critical
and um you know adapting the machine
learning that way
um makes a lot of sense yeah
i think i saw a question from baby but i
can't figure out how to
answer to see the chat there oh uh yeah
um you can um either you could stop
screen sharing or there is a way to pull
it out
i guess
[Music]
well i was just curious if you looked at
um the interpretability of your cnn
i've read a little bit about like
attention maps
we're trying to interpret these yeah
um i haven't actually um
i think a major reason for that and um
there are definitely attention maps all
those things that like look at them
but i think a big problem with them is
like you see that a lot of the cases
that people like to show on their papers
are kind of cherry picked examples where
they show you how well it's working and
not
where it's failing um and there's just a
lot of
i think in my opinion a lot more work
that needs to go into those
into interpreting those models which is
a big reason why you know
for aim2 i used logistic regression
because it was so interpretable
even though you're still using like a
deep learning based metric in there
like understanding like a vascular
severity score you know
it's a little bit more interpretable
than just getting out an answer
right
yeah makes sense thanks
here and i had a quick question that
does really great work
um i kind of want to follow up on on
bill's
comment about clinical context you
showed
um the overall performance on on your
test set in terms of prediction i was
wondering if you could comment
a little bit about the confidence in
individual predictions i'm assuming
there's still
a range um yeah and that that would come
into play if this was used in the clinic
yeah there definitely is going to be um
and that has to be
kind of you know we need to work on that
a little bit more
um but the the confidence definitely you
start to lose it too especially
what i've noticed is when you have
babies who are um a little bit older
and their vascular severity score might
be a little bit higher and the model
doesn't necessarily it they're kind of
edge cases there
so that's definitely something we need
to work on
or you know kind of just examine a
little bit further
great thanks thank you
hey aaron this is ben i have a question
kind of about
it's maybe more clinical um i'm i'm
wondering what the
treatments are for um rop and what
in the clinic can be done to slow
progression and
specifically if you know variations in
like standards of care
interventions might impact the utility
of your models
yeah um so the treatments for rop
there's basically you can do laser
ablation on the vessels that
seem like they're kind of growing out of
control so just blast them with a laser
and you
cause them to scar over um there's also
like a cryotherapy which is
similar you're basically putting like a
cold probe on the outside of the eye to
freeze those
vessels and then you can also use like
an anti-vegf compound
to to basically get rid of the
vegetables in the eye
to stop that growing um that has some
concerns associated with it because
you know you're putting anti-vegf into
an eye that should be growing and
you know it needs to develop with laser
ablation
again you're you're destroying that part
of the retina
so um if you know
if especially when you're talking about
people who maybe over treat you know you
might be
destroying a part of the retina for a
baby that never needed treatment in the
first place
um and so yeah those are kind of some
issues to take
into account here um and i guess your
second part of the question was
basically like how does that factor into
the models correct
yeah and i mean those seem to be kind of
maybe approaches to remedy already
fairly advanced disease i
i wonder if you know you mentioned for
example
the amount of oxygen in the environment
being crucial to the development
yes you know i could imagine someone
trying to
put the eyes in an anoxic environment
right like covered
yeah so i mean that's basically what
they're trying to do is they try to like
finely tune that that oxygen titration
there right
um and you're kind of playing this game
between
you know keeping a baby alive and then
also
not having it develop rop i mean we i
was literally
just talking uh online with a
neonatologist about this
yesterday or two days ago you know kind
of commenting on how it's
it's you know you're just towing that
line there
so that's really the only uh thing that
we have right now you know it's because
we know oxygen is what keeps them alive
but
figuring out how much is the hard part
and and so i guess like to kind of wrap
up the train of thought like
how does that um do you think
any of like for example the levels of
oxygen
does that influence like how um your
models
might uh predict kind of the progression
yeah there's been some interesting work
by actually
an md student in our lab who's been
looking at
basically overall oxygen exposure
you know up to like 30 31 weeks of
like post menstrual aid or whatever um
looking at like how how
that affects whether or not you develop
treatment requiring rop
so we're looking at you know kind of
hoping to add that is actually like
another
piece in this model to further improve
specificity
awesome thanks so much it was a really
fantastic presentation and cool work
thank you ben great um
i'm going to um um uh
stop it there um so again thank you for
a great presentation so
um as i mentioned at the beginning of
the talk